you guys know about Menon ISM it's sort
of feminism for men and is that a fair
explanation feminism from it's men that
want to be empowered to be men how's
that sure that sounded pretty good okay
so the BBC did a report on these guys
it's this is a movement that started
about a year ago and it was originally
just a bunch of guys that online we're
sharing jokes about men and kind of
making fun of the whole thing but now
it's sort of morph into this group of
men mostly online who are quote
expressing the difficulties of being a
man in the 21st century we've got some
some tweets and some photos about some
of the things that these guys have been
talking about I need men anism because
the movie Magic Mike promotes an
unrealistic expectation of how men's
bodies should look you know Ben please
feel this one would you it's tough
because if that's if he's kidding Bravo
well done pretty good if he's serious
what a gigantic jack bag
like I mean you don't so I don't know
you know I don't know but if it's
serious then come on man is this segment
gonna end with you taking your shirt off
cuz you haven't done it in a couple
months I'm already well underway let's
see what else we got we got some tweets
and some other pictures so here's a
series of tweets using the meninist
hashtag so sometimes it's meninist and
sometimes it's men amidst twitter so why
do men have to spend our hard-earned
money on dates when we can get asked out
picked up and fed I like free food too
so there they're trying to turn feminism
on its head why can't men ever get into
a club for free I actually look there
are a lot of MRA people out there that
are extreme in their views and I
disagree with them there are some that
are actually reasonable and they talk
about unfair prosecutorial standards for
men versus women that guy real quick
explain what MRA is for this men's
rights activist right so I'm willing to
have a discussion about the reasonable
points that are made because not all
sexes are created equally when it comes
to certain situations right so that's
fine but that comment right there about
men not being able to get into clubs for
free I couldn't agree more with that I
actually hate when I go into a club and
it's like a titty fest and I like I'm
going there because I want to socialize
with other men
I'm not going there because I want to
socialize with other women all that
somewhere else so yeah that kind of does
frustrate me if you don't want a titty
fest you can step on all those lesbian
bars if you want to go to a club with a
guy you're not getting in unless you
show up at like 9:30 right because they
just don't want guys in there doesn't
make any sense
earlier when you and your Posse Jenkins
Steve and the rest of the crew all got
together you guys put on your nice black
shirts and then went to a club and you
couldn't get in right am i right you
stand out there looking like a bunch of
Schmucks first of all before I answer
that question let me just say that I
want a titty fest you know I I hear you
that there's some do people in the men's
rights movement occasionally stumble on
to a good point
should men get into clubs for no I don't
know it but it's not real like it's all
it's all about an idea that the people
who have power somehow want to feel like
victims so in the end I hear you I would
agree with a couple of their points too
but I would accidentally stumble into
agreeing with a couple of Stalin's
points like it's all horseshit by the
way those those two tweets that we just
show there those are pretty
insignificant things getting into a club
and being taken out on a date like it's
not systemic stuff going they absolutely
are and you know I guess my biggest
argument against m-ras would be just the
idea that feminism is a zero-sum game
right so if women are empowered and
they're able to enter the workforce and
they're paid equally then all of a
sudden men are losing their rights and
men are screwed over and that feminists
want to violate men's rights know women
want simple things like I don't know not
getting raped or I don't know have it
making sure that there is justice when
there is sexual assault or harassment at
the war right so an equal amount for
equal work right I don't want to hear
stupid arguments about how women are the
ones who get knocked up and since we're
the ones that get pregnant well
obviously we don't take our job
seriously we're gonna end up leaving so
we should get paid less no that's a
stupid [ __ ] argument there are plenty
of women out there that a have no
interest in having kids so you can't
just make that judgment from the get-go
and be like if they do end up getting
pregnant
a lot of women continue working not even
because they really want to because in
this economy you absolutely have to
right and then one other thing there's
another argument that oh look women are
getting better jobs than men are this
and that when more women are employed
than men these days you know look at the
the rates of employment in the United
States no you have to look at the types
of jobs women get hired at they don't
get high paying high level jobs as often
as men do right so if you want to have a
discussion you can't compare apples and
oranges you got to look at apples and
apples and in this case a lot of times
MRA people will ignore that you want to
have a discussion about prosecutions you
want to have a discussion about child
support you want to have a discussion
about matrimony no not much matrimony
what's the thing that you have to pay
spousal support alimony all those things
all those things are legitimate topics
to discuss in a mature way but as I'm
sure you're gonna see in the comment
sections of this video a lot of people
are uninterested in having a mature
rational discussion about it there's
this very us-versus-them mentality and
also there's a lot of frustration about
guys who can't maybe have sex with
everyone that they want to have sex with
this notion that women only want bad
boys and women don't want me because I'm
a good guy usually good guys don't make
comments like that full of
disappointment and it has nothing to do
with men and ISM more feminism and
you're not gonna get to have sex with
who you want to and you're not gonna be
able to get to a club you want to and
you're not gonna be able to go to the
restaurant you want to and if you want
to go out with a girl you got a buyer
dinner maybe not you'll probably split
it with you right
that happens seems to but that's not
anything to do with feminism and your
last three minutes was like impassioned
and awesome because that's what the
issues of feminism are so don't engage
with them over whether they should get
in the club because what they're trying
to do is redefine feminism and turn
feminism
into these little things where [ __ ]
women just want to have their way right
but it's not it's about what you said
it's about equal pay and equal rights
and respect and safety being able to
dress how you want and go out and not
think I hope nothing happens to me so
I'm not gonna engage with him on
anything yeah well actually I mean you
both have pretty much summed this up in
a pretty spectacular way let's just look
it's just like two more tweets just two
so we have a little bit of a broader
sense of the types of things
why can't she open the door for me again
it's the type of if they're kidding it's
funny
bright bright you know I've been happy
to send that right and when we were
looking at the tweets on this just leave
it represent when we were looking at the
tweets on this I was having trouble
figuring out if these were jokes and
finally you can take bikini pics with
your friends but when I take shirtless
pictures with my friends I'm gay so
funny
he might be I don't know I mean I'm sure
those pictures movement of men well you
know what so there you go equality
that's what it's all about what do you
think let us know in the comments right
down below
[Music]